chin how was your uh did you go fishing
camping
thanks for bringing that up we did go
fishing and we actually both caught
keepers my girlfriend and i
i have the pictures ready he's all
thought you'd never have you never asked
he finally
thickest yeah people a lot of people
were saying you look like a little nicky
oh yeah oh that's that's exactly
that's a good reference everyone said
that was most of the like
that's exactly what it is oh that is i
didn't even think of that yeah
oh my god you're right holy [ __ ] i've
never seen that was he like a devil or
something
he's the devil's son he's trying to save
his dad oh gotta go
it's an underrated movie yeah holy [ __ ]
it doesn't
yeah nicki mm-hmm that's hilarious
i was going for more of a big ass little
[ __ ]
shout out to maverick uh coffee on uh
that's
right that was our spot mm-hmm who did
your hair like that
he did i just did it to make chappelle
laugh okay yeah and i cracked up
oh that's so there's mine whoa there you
are 16-inch rainbow trout
that's the most i've ever seen you smile
yeah and actually
i ate i finally caught one worth keeping
dude
right there too you covered all of it
look at that see
as you can see there it's all talking
[ __ ] yeah i know
and then it goes all the way over here
is that a rainbow trout 16 yeah rainbow
trout you know what's up
i know what's up dog damn dog [ __ ]
that's beautiful and my girlfriend
caught a freaking
for the very first time that she ever
went fishing a 15 inch
large mouth fast yeah she got a thick um
yeah ass is good
her very first fish she caught this very
first very first fish ever was it cold
out there looks cold it was cold yeah
yeah
i like her damn that's a good ass
[ __ ] cat i know
it's ridiculous no she actually put it
in herself
yeah we're we're so excited i bet it was
on like donald count when we got back
yeah yeah
you got that bad
what did you use to catch them i trolled
with the crankbait
fire tiger paddle what do they call it
trolling trolling yeah so if you go two
miles per hour on a boat
you leave your your pole out there with
a line and then you just
put out a certain amount of depth of
wine and they just
cruise from was that the only one you
caught uh so she caught two she caught a
trout as well
yeah i'm killing it and but it got it
got off when when she wrote real
close to the boat how did you kill those
fish i used a bonker
yeah a bonker it's like a little bat and
you hit them
because i don't want them to suffer you
know you know a lot of people just put
them in a bucket
you know what i'm saying and they just
yeah and they just they just suffer so
you smash their skull
and they have because we had to do that
in aquaculture right yeah yep so you
know how whitey bulger died in prison
that's how he kills his fish that's a
chance it's the most
it's the most ethical way actually no we
put them in uh freezing water
freezing water yeah so they slow down
that's [ __ ]
he's an up class still teaching us how
to fillet them
imagine this so if you would if it was
you right if it was you
would you rather be knocked out before
they do something to you or would you
rather
be frozen or something else well don't
fishes freeze over anyways in the winter
like
yeah they freeze over and then go
they're good to go afterwards so like
you're frozen and then you're
especially true would you rather freeze
to death or be knocked out and then i
think it's different for us than fishing
but i mean if it was you guys but do you
knock them out or you kill them i think
you actually you actually kill them by
doing it yeah yeah but it's just how
many times you got to hit him
i did it twice god damn i need to get on
the first try
no just for good measure i did yeah you
want to do it twice and then i felt the
the head cave in on the second one oh my
god which is just like buddy bulger
hey do you uh lock in the side how do
they kill like
when they get like large swordfish tuna
how do they kill those i think they just
kind of like leave them there
no you can't so you you you you never
see when the swordfish
gets on the boat yeah yeah what's up
everybody and then uses his
sword for a nose and he kills the people
yeah i know you know what
makes me happy when that happens with
huge halibut they they use a gun
they shoot the brand with the gun see i
was thinking even with a swordfish you
gotta use a gun
maybe or you bomb do we have any video
of them trying to take out a swordfish
well
it's a beast yeah because they're
[ __ ] like marlins and [ __ ]
or like those two those those like
thousand pound tunas where the [ __ ] they
are
but why why would you want to catch a
sword fish you can't eat it right oh my
swordfish
delicious oh add it yeah oh well you get
it
literally every fish restaurant is is
grouper it's all about this video
grouper you know like you like grouper
uh you're not
you're not supposed to really eat
grouper yeah there's a certain size
because you know there's giant groupers
or goliath groupers but i think uh
certain groupers they taste like bass i
think oh got it
like like a saltwater house even though
you can eat swordfish that's amazing
like if you don't like real fishy meat
fish is almost like a steak it's like a
real
thicker like not fishy uh fish yeah
because they they call it like swordfish
steaks okay it's like a dense fish
so it's like the whole way it's the
whole plate on there and then it's like
it's just like a like a fillet of
swordfish
damn swordfish it seems intense i want
something man
swordfish papa does oh yeah but that's a
down stop restaurant
no it's probably did you order a bunch
of chicken tenders from there
you ordered 70 chicken tenders let's not
bring that back
they're not showing them how to take no
they're showing an assassin's creed
video game
by the way great movie as well damn
michael fassbender yeah you hit no
youtube
thing damn best way to dispatch yeah i
just don't get because there's
there's so many challenges
you got to shoot so i blow out my fish
too you cut the gills yeah
after after you bonk them though well
that's a suffer too though
how you get close enough well they
usually bring around the boat once
they've they're exhausted
oh for fire do you have seen a swordfish
fight no
dog is there a video oh yeah bring that
[ __ ] up gin they're what is it they're
a swordfish fighting in the water i mean
sometimes it takes i mean
a lot they're jumping out of the water
like they're [ __ ] nuts
you mean actually catching them or with
them fighting oh okay
catch them they fight fight they'll
break they'll break the lines
a lot of times sorry like 10 yeah look
at that
big one that's what i'm saying how do
you [ __ ] kill that thing no you ain't
no way
yeah that thing i don't want to eat that
kind of 22 minutes
they fight like crazy they take 22
minutes to get a swordfish
i've heard people fishing for like hours
it will take hours to bring them in
oh yeah oh because they put up a good
fight yeah real big
yeah huge fight probably broke his line
but there you those you'll see some
where they're jumping out of the
there's some right there they seem right
oh [ __ ] god damn aren't they cool
looking yeah
it's kind of a shame you gotta have a
strong back to fish oh
jumping yep and they have like you said
they jumped in boats
and the sword has impaled the fishermen
before oh yeah yeah
so how do you know what kind of bait are
they using to get that chin
i think mackerel what is it a full-size
mackerel what's that another fish it
probably tastes like chicken
yeah that's giant look how big he is
he's exhausted right yeah
get the floor off fighting for his life
you know the fly behind me
it's fine for his life you know it's
food it's food circle of life god
damn dog and those things are like so
i'm sitting on the couch
it's probably bigger than the couch
you're getting that couch yeah from from
tip to
tip hey hide your keys anyone seen that
2002 nissan
it's not 2002 it's 2012. oh no no still
no
you have tape around it too yeah hundred
keys
i was talking about fishing right all
right say less um yeah but i i've never
been fishing so
whatever fish nah especially deep sea
fish a different animal right
literally different but now louisiana is
the catfishing right yeah but
we have little lakes though so we don't
have swordfish or big yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're usually catching that and
where the ocean floor swordfish is oh
yeah saltwater they're also
so what's the big what's the what's
what's the like most massive fish you
can catch
i think grouper a group yeah goliath
tunas though tunas are huge but i think
goliath groupers are like
enormous yeah you going sizzle though
you get that you catch the right tuna
they're worth so much money oh yeah
really so much money
damn and they just caught a big uh tuna
chin dude i would love to go fishing
yeah i'd be down it's just it's the
whole day it's too good i mean that's
fine
yeah for the you know i don't think i
would do it i bet we could fish when
we're in uh
palm beach yeah let's go fishing it's a
great
god damn yeah they're here that's the
nutty professional fishes
yeah they're ugly though yeah do you so
we eat those oh yeah groupers there
uh i don't think you're supposed to the
small ones you get the smaller ones
right yeah it all depends they're
they're like protected too but it's like
groupers are aggressive too
yeah groupers are [ __ ] with you but
isn't it it's expensive though
right
like if you ordered it off a menu yeah
i've never seen it on a menu
no i'm not sure no were you oh yes but
yeah tuna get
enormous tuna i think it's crazy
expensive what's you know what that's
most expensive yeah they're worth
millions sizzlers some are worth
millions
yeah something else is stop it
in japan they like go early to pick out
the best tunas like bring up that
one some dude just caught a tuna i
forget how much they paid for it
someone paid a [ __ ] ton of money for it
are you serious million dollar tuna cot
600 pound uh giant bluefin tuna cot yeah
like if you've had toro sushi this is
the tuna that they're talking about this
tycoon
3.1 million giant tuna think about the
most expensive
600 pounds where are they located though
in the ocean
tunas yeah in the ocean the atlantic
but here's what's [ __ ] up is uh
chicken of the sea come on now
but here's what's [ __ ] up malik is
japan does they eat so much uh
tuna they're like they're becoming
extinct like they do so much [ __ ]
[ __ ] up [ __ ] to their seas like tuna's
hard to get by
yeah so it's red so they don't mate a
lot that's what you're saying
no we just we just harvested them way
too much way too much yeah
so that's all they eat over there but i
heard if you eat that [ __ ] a lot you get
mercury poisoning if you eat way too
much you're dead about salmon you gotta
eat something yeah i got a ton that's
why that people were making fun of
jeremy piven
back in the day he said he had mercury
poisoning
from eating sushi but you would have to
eat a ton of sushi
like crazy amounts of shoes i think
chelsea handler had got mercury
yeah that's a lie though i don't know
you might have high mercury levels but
you know how much [ __ ] fish you would
have happened to mark hayes
irish irish mark that never happened to
mark yes he did he had to go to the
doctor that never happened why would he
love not not from what would he lie
he just doesn't eat a lot of tuna you'd
have to eat so much like to get
straight up mercury poisoning is it like
canned tuna
or is it because cancun is a little
different i know a lot of people will
get arsenic poisoning from eating too
much canned foods
like sardines and stuff like that what
does it call it arsenic arsenic
yeah and chinese there's a lot of fat
you know you're doing great dog how
about that when i get off stage at the
lab factory
right away you go bro i figured out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song